un chien après un sachet de drogue une
interpellation à cheval le sauvetage
d'une conductrice
pour cette nouvelle édition des
rencontres de la sécurité une vingtaine
de policiers gendarmes et pompiers se
sont pliés au jeu de la démonstration
mais pas seulement ils ont aussi tenu à
expliquer étape par étape chaque
opération
une centaine d'élèves et quelques
dizaines de passants ont assisté captivé
aux exercices
ce qui n'a pas manqué de réveiller chez
certains leur fibre patriotique
c'est une immense à la fois fierté voilà
que notre pays soit performant dans
toutes ses actions et en même temps où
une immense admiration pour que ces
hommes et ces femmes qui sont vraiment
nos services
pourtant les relations entre les forces
de l'ordre et la population ont connu
des hauts et des bas ces derniers mois
la manifestation intervient dans un
contexte tendu après l'attaqué des
policiers dans l'essonne mais selon un
récent sondage 82 % des français gardent
une bonne opinion de la police le but
des démonstrations c'est de rapprocher
la population des gendarmes des
policiers des pompiers à travers des
commandes des opérations dynamique ce
qui permet aussi à la population de se
rendre compte un petit peu des
différentes facettes de notre métier nul
doute que la manifestation aura suscité
des vocations s'engager c'est avant tout
faire preuve de courage et de dévouement
c'est en tout cas le message clair qu'on
voulu faire passer les organisateurs de
cette journée